so let's see even the camera seems to be
right angle because the last week I
didn't set up the camera to be facing me
so uh there is a video without my
present which uh I I don't mind but it
looks a bit bit dead if there is just
some just some voice talking what we
what we went uh through last last time
we saw that our world is Rich of data
we might already know or we also try try
to point it out that this data is not
always reliable there is always some
noise in the in the measurements you saw
it in in many of your uh lab exercises
and the question is how we are going to
going to deal with this uh with this
situation how are we going to make sense
of the of the data which are which are
having some troubles where the values of
this of these data are slightly off
because there was there was something
sometimes it's a uh systematic error you
you heard it in your uh in many of your
of your lab exercises yeah something
something is off somebody didn't
calibrate a a device uh and there is a
like standard error of the which which
comes from uh many many SES small errors
would accumulate and will will will
actually uh give you some some
measurement noise and at the end we
should be we should be able to uh to
make some sense of the of the data in
terms of finding a model finding
some function some some kind of a um
some kind of algorithm that uh that will
make sense of this of this data despite
that there are some uh some some
problems for example with the with the
noises so this is what databased
modeling is about part of the database
modeling is system identification that's
where the where the title of our course
come come from where system
identification is more when we are
talking about the dynamic systems we
will not start right away with the
dynamic systems we will slowly slowly
move in into that um
so this is what we already already
discussed uh in our uh modeling in
process industry class this was actually
the types of models that we that we
built So-Cal first principles models so
the models are coming from the
principles of physics yeah so that's
that's what uh what uh what gives gives
this gives this name and so those those
are the models which are based on the
physics in our world for this course we
will be in the in the world of of the of
the database models and uh we will see
some static and dynamic models how how
we can how we can find them how uh we
can even uh look at some linear or or
nonlinear models some very little about
the about the state estimation which is
which of course is some technique that
tries to process the the data remove
remove Some Noise
maybe okay so uh
Let's uh let's jump in and now I will
surprise that I have a that I have a
Slovak slide hope this works well so
this is the set of slides that I didn't
specifically prepare for uh for for this
lecture I prepare it for some lecture
what is it the researchers nights
researchers European researchers night
that uh usually is around September so
it was prepared actually for school kids
to yeah show them a bit of the uh of the
probability show them how how it works
and uh our our question for for today
would be uh how we can really model the
noise in the data how can we model that
we have some uncertainty in the in the
data how can we make make sense of the
of the data before even even building
building some uh some model and and uh
one of the of the ways is to understand
probability and do and do some do some
statistics Let's uh let's try to dwell
into into that uh maybe if we have if we
have time I was yesterday at the uh
there was uh probably you you you saw
you saw it at the electrical engineering
faculty there was this Slovak researcher
mikal vco who is one of the founders of
the Google deep mind and well really a
top top scientist and well he was
talking about the uh lm's large language
models you might uh you might think what
this what does this have to do well
everything llms are just applied
statistics uh what he what he present in
many equations with some uh mean values
some standard deviations probability
this is how CH GPT is is trained and uh
yeah if we have time I will even even
tell you we will we will see what we
could do if we can train multiple times
to GPT we could even even make it to
give us like a confidence in the answers
this is the big problem that you get the
output from CH GPT but uh it's nobody is
telling you like this output is 80%
confident to be correct this output is
only 20% confident to be to be correct
that's a that's a big problem now so on
the way on the way there what's a what's
a probability
well there is some simple definition
what am I doing wrong
here see so probability you know we know
this from from high school it tries to
express that some event can uh can
happen with with a certain certain
likelihood so it expresses the
possibility in some mathematical
mathematical terms from from 0 to one
yeah we we know this and one of the best
testing devices is a is a is a dice so
let's uh let's try some some
experiment uh we will we saw a
visualization of the data uh last week
we uh we uh looked at the at the case of
histogram so here we will be building
building a a histogram uh the his will
be telling us what we will basically see
whether we get one two 3 four five or
six on the dice actually if you want you
can make a you can make a physical
experiment with this if this dice
works okay so one two three uh please
you can you can try doing your your own
own experiments just give it give it a
give it a try so Hannah which number
would you would you roll ah roll
it yeah that was number number two let's
see whatever whatever experiment does so
uh one one
okay okay what happened is it likely or
or or not
likely okay two again
[Laughter]
yeah okay H what
happens one one would one would one
would say that the statistics is is is
getting
off ah six okay
five okay well it's it's it's getting
there
so that wasn't a proper proper rolling
yeah
okay ah five very good okay so uh what
we are what we are uh witnessing why why
for example we didn't see number three
or or number four is the is the problem
with the with the
dice the number
of experiments is not sufficient yeah
like big numers or something like that
we try to roll it
time exactly yeah yeah well we we'll
we'll see that we will not not throw the
dice we can go up to six millions in in
this in this slide so six millions would
would take us a lot of time and lot of
memory well because it would be hard to
to keep it in our heads yeah Mikel said
said it also right what if what if the
dice is unfair yeah if it's if it's
unfair then there will be there there
will be some some problems in our our
histogram we would we would try to see
some numbers are occurring uh more
frequent than than than the others but
really uh well we we cannot cannot say
from the small amount of experiments so
here we will see couple of uh couple of
experiments uh on the top we are
actually even even counting how many
times we we threw through a dice and
this is I promise this is done with a
fair dice because it's simulated in
Matlab yeah I didn't uh sit in my in my
office and uh throw the dies for six
million times that we will that we will
see okay but U yeah let's see so
similar similar to to our
dice so so far is the response of Matlab
so five six exactly exactly ones there
is there is one there is six there is
four coming and more and more I'm
throwing
let's say let's keep it until until 20
yeah now so even even with the 100% fair
fair dice like same person is throwing
the the same same dice we get we get
this this result pretty easily yeah in
20 20
attempts so it might seem okay this this
dice is maybe throwing only the only the
number number six almost in in in half
of the cases yeah some some g games
where the throwing the six is a is a is
is the best result might be might be
easier easier with this one um so if we
have a Matlab and we can simulate this
so what do we what do we do we get more
attempts yeah so if we get if we get 100
attempts
H it's already already quite a different
picture yeah right it doesn't doesn't
seem that the six is dominant now the
five seems to be dominant but not not
really yeah only only relatively
relatively slightly um let's now try to
do some um some exponential growth of
the attempts so let's go to let's go to
thousand um so the these uh small bar
here that's the result from our from our
previous attempt yeah so if we had had
aund of hundred of Trials then they are
still still still kept here as as to as
a reminder what what happened what
happened uh before when we only had th
100 attempts so thousand it's still does
it look like we like we expect already
or or not
no no which one is which one is off how
would you how would you calculate
it what do we
expect how do you now calculate the the
probability that we throw uh six on the
on the
dice wanted outcome dived by all the
possibilities mhm which which which
would here be roughly if you read the
read the graph and put it to numbers so
the number of successful attempts versus
the number of all all the all the
attempts so
roughly yeah 4 six let's say 140 divided
by by thousand yeah so
it's getting close to to 16 how much is
16 1 15 is 0.2 yeah so it should be
something something
smaller let's see let's see what happens
once uh once we roll more roll more
means now we have 10,000 so here is
still the Thousand histogram there is
the 10,000 ATM oh sorry there is 100
ATMs histogram thousand ATMs histogram
now we have a 10,000 and yeah the The
Columns are getting even out as we as we
would expect now we go to
100,000 they are really really
equalizing
billion not bad and uh such that uh our
m is easy let's just do six million
attempts and with the Six Million
attempts where do we where do we land
well we actually start to see quite
quite nicely that each each of our each
of our numbers on the on the dice is uh
equally likely and we get 1 million 1es
1 million twos 1 million 3es if we are
uh throwing the dice 6 million times so
at this point we of course conclude what
that uh ah we can we can make this uh
this
histogram somehow
uh somehow somehow normalize it such
that well we we don't care about the
absolute numbers but we care about the
proportionality about the ratios so this
would this would
mean this would mean yeah we have the we
have the one six here and then we can
say well we calculate the probability of
an event of
throwing three on the dice six on the
dice as the number number of successful
times when we throw for example three
and we divide it by the number of
attempts this is I guess pretty clear
from the high school from everything
before you you even even even saw
yeah so now let's uh let's uh make a
standard standard detour and this is I
don't know whether whether you whether
you saw this this is a standard example
uh when uh we will be uh continuing with
the this dice game but now let's say
that we that we will throw two di at the
same time and we will not be interested
in the uh in the individual numbers but
in in the sum yeah so how much do our uh
how much uh does our uh do our numbers
sum sum to yeah so this will be this
will be number number
12 uh if we if we have just one dice we
would we would see basically this
outcome because yeah we will be just
summing summing this one so uh what
would what would change what would be
what would be
expect what will how will it look like
maybe somebody who saw this example
before
will should we probably turn into
something like the ocean curve but it
will look something like that because
the numbers MH six or seven are probably
like most
likely of them M
mhm sounds good sounds good yeah because
what uh we have uh we have this uh this
uh possibilities yeah if we if we just
uh without throwing any any dices if we
just uh again do the same same trick
number of uh of successful attempts
versus the number of attempts so uh we
have uh how many uh so this is rolling
one dice this is rolling another dice so
six possible outcomes six possible
outcomes we have 36 possible possible
outcomes for the sum on the two but as
as Adam is mentioning it well if we look
now at the frequency if you if we try to
make some some kind of a histogram well
three for example is here only twice but
seven yeah that dominates because we
have 6+ one and 5 plus two and four +
three and so on and and and so forth so
uh this game is already already changing
and we don't have no longer have this
nice uniform uniform probability our uh
model of this uh of this game would
actually actually look something like
this and uh this will be exactly this
number of attemps the this the histogram
of how we how we play the play the game
and the number seven we would be would
be most likely is the is the one which
which comes uh most often uh the gausian
curve not yet tell
me okay good good so we are not yet at
the at the gausian curve but we can get
there pretty easily what if we
now change our change our game and uh
instead of two dice we throw three dice
so it's no we cannot cannot we cannot
longer uh don't know whether whether to
say that 10 or or 11 is the is the most
uh most likely
one there so what what would change yeah
the the lowest possible outcome is when
we get 111 on the on on each of on the
on the three dices yeah and the highest
possible is 666 so we get we get 18 and
again this uh three and four and five
and two that gives us so that is are the
sum of 10 and 11 so let's now continue
continue this game that we will that we
will take more and more Dice and throw
throw so this is this is the game with
the four dices this is the game with
five this is the game with six we start
to see that something something is
appearing some shape is appearing seven
dice eight dice nine
10 how long do we
continue uh 11 already the the the beins
are or the the range on the horizontal
axis is is so large these beans become
become
smaller and the in the visualization
yeah the width of of them and if we
continue I think the number number 20 so
would be a good one good one to up
because what when we were throwing two
dices we we had the we had the seven
number seven as the most probable
outcome well now we have 10 times more
dices so we have number 70 as the
probably the highest highest peak here
yeah also the visualization is maybe not
not perfect or the number of atoms
wasn't uh wasn't uh wasn't enough
yeah and this sort of a curve is uh
already reminding us of something and
this something was even what uh Germans
used to put on their uh on their
currency yeah so Germans they they they
put mass in the in the center of the uh
of the 10 10 Mark bill so this bell bell
curve even with a with the equation
known as a gausian curve and of course
they are celebrating the best
mathematicians probably to ever live so
far Carl fredrich
gaus okay so uh if Germans had this on
on their on their money on their on
their notes uh we should probably
probably have a have a look at uh at
what this uh what this function what
this function does yeah we will we will
rewrite it and and have some fun with
with that with that
function today so our
function the bell curve is a is a
socalled
uh
probability
probability density function
and it's a and it's a long long name but
the good abbreviation for that is to is
to write
PDF sounds already something something
something uh sounds familiar but it's
not the portable document format but
it's probability probability density
function how is this in Slovak
how do do do you remember so now we will
have a bit of bit of the terms that uh
that come with in this Pro probability
realm and uh it's it's also also good to
to know the the Slovak
Alternatives do you do you particularly
recall how these functions were
called uh okay uh it's it's it's it's
not not yet a gausian curve it it can be
now any so probability density function
would be would be we can even uh how do
I
move okay wow no we can we can get a
probability density function even for
the
so-called come here even for the
so-called uniform uniform distribution
and it won't be the the the the function
with e to the power of something and and
so on
so
uh in Slovak and maybe you haven't heard
it so
the just put it like
this I I would say that I I like more
the the probability density density
function you will you will see you will
see why um it will basically as the
function name says it will tell us some
uh likely likeliness of a of an event
event
occurring with the dice when we have
only six possible outcomes that one is
easy to interpret with for example
temperature in this room where we can
measure really in the in the continuous
domain that's already kind of kind of
hard to tell like uh what is the
probability of the measuring the
temperature
25.7
2784 You Name It Whatever whatever uh
number of decimal places so it's this
concept of uh saying throwing a three or
one on the dice is is one one six uh is
a is a bit bit distorted it but don't
worry there will there will be a there
will be a way how to go about it so uh
then let's let's say like a something
like a
definition uh an event would would obey
and now we go for
the no
normal or
gausian the those two are are are really
really synonyms normal or or gausian uh
distribution so normal distribution
gausian distribution whoever talks about
it maybe if Germans talk about it they
would they would put the word gaus if uh
somebody non German talks about it they
would they would uh they would uh use
the use the word normal so
some then we say some even X has this
normal
distribution so the capital x would be
something which we which we call a
random
variable so capital x is
a random
variable now pra in
Slovak and
the this this still the sign should
basically say what is what is written in
in this uh even would obey
distribution in in these these words and
the and the N should be standing there
for for normal the whole world even the
Germans right capital n and not g so the
so the normal distribution would then be
defined with
some mu and with some with some Sigma
functions do you recall the the the Muse
and and sigmas from the from the high
school
maybe maybe sometimes you use
some instead of me you use the notation
xbar even in Slovak shouted at me what
are what are these
yeah or well every let's let's let's
let's let's call it mean that would be
that would be the the better yeah
English is is is not
that not not that cool in distinguishing
mean and and average will will make
sense of it so the
two let's call it parameters are
me some somebody some people like like
call it call it
xbar uh which is
the mean and I or mean value and I uh
like the uh English uh literature also
call it expected
value which is uh which is quite quite
nice quite nice wording they would even
even say even write it like me is this
kind of
e over over X so if I if my data are are
distributed according to the to the
normal distribution I expect the even X
if if it is throwing a dice measuring uh
temperature in this room uh calculating
what will be my
likely result at the next exam then the
expected value will be will be this
number so uh this here is still kind of
uh uh kind of abstract thing because
it's a it's it's a it's a random
variable there is still this uncertainty
this here is already making sense like
what can we expect what can we expect uh
from our from our our dice game well we
could already already calculate let's
take some let's take this this simple
simple example uh our our mean would be
would be actually the number number
seven here that would be that would be
the the most most expected the well the
most expect the expected
one
and so what this was the Slovak word we
call
it that's the that's the word yeah
[Music]
so you heard it
yes no
good the second second M mysterious term
and maybe uh note uh there is uh
[Music]
usually this uh this this notation uh
people would use either Sigma square or
or Sigma we'll we'll see what is the
what is the what is the difference
so Sigma is something which we would
call that's the
standard
deviation in Slovak what would you
sayil exactly yeah some some some people
do like half translation like uh
standard nilka some people do uh do the
full TR full
translation okay
um we'll see in a in a in a in a second
what it what it does and uh if we are if
we if we should use uh Sigma Square this
uh in in
English would be called VAR Varan we
will talk talk a lot about the about the
variance it's very helpful
concept and in Slovak this is
[Music]
rosil you you you recall this you recall
this very
good all right so let's now try to do uh
not not go to any more terminology and
and ter terms Let's uh let's see what uh
what this function from the from the
German Bill German note uh would uh
would tell us and and might tell us so
we have uh one over there is this
Sigma uh square root of 2 pi interesting
we'll see why it's there and uh we have
the E exponential to the minus x- u^ 2 /
2 * Sigma
squ so
this PDF of of of
X where I try to now write lowercase x
which which is the outcome of an of an
event so this is going to tell us How
proportionally likely is the value of x
uh is is the is the value of x is the uh
is the outcome X 1/ Sigma squ < TK of 2
pi e to the minus and there was a
fraction x -
mu squared / 2 2 Sigma squar
kind of complicated uh function to even
even look at yeah it's it's scary I I
give you that uh let's try to break it
into into into smaller smaller terms or
let's even try to to have a look uh at
the at the simpler simpler function
let's maybe try to have a look at the at
the the function where mu will be equal
to
zero and
uh this Sigma will be will be equal to
one somebody would uh would call this
situation if uh if we have these two
these two parameters if we for example
now right that our uh temperature
measurement in the in the room obas
standard
or gaan sorry normal or gaan
distribution with mean zero and standard
deviation one then we are talking about
the standard gausian distribution or
Stan standard normal
distribution standard
[Music]
normal distribution
good so in this case
our our function would look
like like this Square < TK of 2 pi e to
the what what remains there like
12 -
x² right if I plug in the MU and mu and
sigma
good uh so let's just let's just plot it
now but uh we can for example do what we
definitely know the function x
square right so let's try
it I want
to I want to have like like
three graphs B beside each other if you
are making notes that's that's what you
that's what you might also want to have
well function x x squ how does it look
like yeah
exactly so we have value of zero at some
point our at some
point some point zero which happens to
be to be our our mean
our x square function looks looks like
this maybe I I make it a bit leaner
because a bit later I want
to I want to want to plot
slightly slightly wider version of it
okay um
so what would happen now if we if
we if we if we make make this make this
function
negative so minus x^2 what would change
How would how would the the picture look
like it's concave yeah it's concave
exactly and uh now this zero here will
will move as the as the maximum yeah you
already already saw this
good and now the but again we have the
we have this maximum at this uh at this
mean now the last step how do we
apply yeah um how do we apply this uh
exponential
transformation the one half won't be a
problem we are just we are just uh just
sketching it the one half is only is
only telling telling us how fast this uh
this this goes to the to the negative uh
infinity or to the negative uh values
but how how would the how would the
shape uh shape change
exponential
function with
quadratic exponential function with
quadratic okay so uh what what do we
this this
function
function yes uh and we can say that if
the exponent is equal to one is going
to be
mhm
yeah continue continue on this on this
line of thought and if exponent is equal
to that's what we that's what we are
more after exp is equal to one so no we
don't care about one if the exponent is
equal to Tres to find some other number
oh zero good what happens then then it's
going to be
one and that's so uh what will the
exponential function is increasing right
so uh if we if we already if we have a
maximum of this of this function at at
Point at point zero will this remain to
be to be
maximum
yes yes it will now I'm thinking whether
whether you whether you you you've done
this uh this transformation in the uh in
the in the optimization class because
sometimes you can take like a logorithm
which is also also increasing increasing
function but okay let's how the original
function
looks which which original one the one
we want to
get
Parabola
ah well
uh that that's it let's let let's just
let
just exactly
exactly I
know good good thinking yeah uh if if we
are if we are trying to draw a gaan
curve we will we will draw a gausian
curve um okay so uh let's let's do it
Point by point so at the point
zero we get what x square minus uh Time
- one2 will still be a zero e to the 0
will be will be one uh and now so our
values so how does this
exponential no so the exponential
function yeah we all know it we all we
all seen
it some some specific points
well our minus X2 only takes negative
values so we will be only only only in
this in this part of the of the graph
and the and and our values will be at
maximum one and at minimum they will
tend
to zero
exactly so that's that's the that's the
transformation yeah our seemingly
infinite t here they here they would
transform they would curve such that
we'll get a we'll get the minimum or
let's say better better say infimum yeah
because it's not not anything that we
can that we can
reach everybody cool cool with that at
your exercises you
will you will you will try to try to
plot this you will generate some some
data to to plot this so we will you will
play with
that
um so if this is
a if this is a probability density
function it's uh so it's not the not not
the probability it itself yet what would
uh and why is there since we already
started with it why is this funny one
over square root of 2 pi there um
um what's going to
happen
if if I take our
dice distribution where is that um maybe
let's take the one with the where is the
one with the numbers
uh will it start from the ah no
perfect so if I now
uh
calculate uh what is the probability of
throwing 1 2 3 four five or six on the
on the dice how would I how would I get
how how would I
proceed or let's let's let's do it the
other way around try try thinking about
uh one of the one of the questions that
uh that we might that we might have here
uh like what How likely is it that I
throw this and that I don't want to
don't want to put anything into your
into your mouth but uh uh try to think
about the about the the questions that
you that you were trying to find answers
when you when you saw this previously
what can we ask
we can ask for example uh How likely is
it that I throw an even number yeah 2 4
2 46 and how do we how do we calculate
that or how how how is it what's the
likelihood what's the probability that I
throw an an even number 50% mhm how can
we get it from from here because uh
every possil has the same probability
and of all possible numbers
are okay uh if I if I if I if I make it
make it harder so uh okay so if I if I
say uh that you throw uh one one or six
then you would
say then then you would say it's a oneir
of the of the cases so it will be 0.333
right positive outcome by
possible yes but well we we we already
already have it here we already have
have the model but uh what we can what
we can actually do we can now now use
these individual probabilities of the
successful events occurring and and we
can we can make a what's the word
not not joint probability but uh uh well
I canot recall recall the word not in
not in Slovak not in not in English but
uh no I know how to write it
mathematically but
like yes we can we can we can just uh
sum so if we if we have or uh or event
so we can just just sum sum the
probability of two sum the probability
of four sum the probability of six 1 6 1
6 1 six together 3 six is 1/2 that's the
probability of throwing an an even
number we can ask different questions
and this is already harder what is the
probability that I throw uh one twice in
a row what is the probability that
Hannah
threw yeah there is a multiplication and
that's that's a joint probability we
will we will we will we will see it so
uh if I so I take the the probability of
the of the event one and what we
actually have here is the probability
density of the of the event event that I
that I throw one on the on the dice and
we we process
it
so what is the probability of throwing
one two one or two or three or four or
five or
six yeah good that's what so one and we
would get it as 1 16 1 6 16 1 six yeah
six times one six
so it what what what we have have done
now uh we went through all the
possibilities and we summed all the
probabilities of the different events
for the for the dice example and we got
one that means that uh if this function
should be similar representation of a
probability of some event then it should
have the same same property that if we
go through all the possible uh possible
we
can I would do it like take
this and we divide it into like six
compartments
not no it's it's it's not possible it's
it's not not not divisible it's it's
continuous mhm so when we integrate the
function
one exactly so uh
our probability density function and
each probability density function even
the uniform one with the diis we we saw
it we went through all the discrete
events 1 2 3 4 1 6 one 16 one one six +
1 16 + one 16 and and we get the number
of number one so we should be able to do
the same thing with the with the
probability density density function if
we if we integrate this function e to
the minus one 12 x x² we should we
should get
one uh let's test our good old friend
mlab and this is now
particularly particularly challenging to
do to do Matlab on a on a tablet but
well uh let's try I did some preparation
otherwise it would take take so so long
uh let's
say that we
have let's maybe start almost from
scratch copy let's
define what is this disconnected okay
h i shouldn't have shouldn't have tapped
it okay I don't care let's see hopefully
it still works I no it needs to connect
good so what we do we try defining our
our
function familiar with this kind of
notation have you
okay maybe not maybe not everybody but
this is how we we can how we can have
have fun with the so you don't need to
always write the function if it's just
one line of code in in Matlab you can
Define it through this through this
function handle and uh let's let's now
do the integral of this function come
on
copy so we take integral of the function
fun from minus infinity to Infinity
why is it not
one can we help
it coefficient like sare two exactly
exactly so what if I
take square root of 2 pi and you already
see the answer but just just to to see
that I'm not not cheating here
H we get we get exactly exactly the the
the same same number 2.5 and so
on so if we
take integral this function we get 2.5
and something and in order to obey this
this property that we need to be certain
if some of the events must happen so
either the temperature is uh minus
infinity in this room or is something
some reasonable reasonable finite number
or is or is plus infinity it has to
happen yeah so that's why that's why
there there needs to be a probability of
of one and this is the magical constant
so this is the
2.5 five
something good it somehow Works uh Works
mathematically but we still have hav uh
haven't made
it uh to the point where we can now ask
the ask the reasonable reasonable
questions um let's
say unfortunately we need we need
another function for this but I promise
this is this is the last one for for
today and this is the function which we
which with which we will calculate not
probability density but the probability
itself and this function is
called
cumulative density
function
no sorry cumulative
distribution too much talking about
density since we before had PDF now we
have
CDF and the Slovak term this one is
nice slak term is
distribu
distrib
[Music]
fun how it goes uh notation wise so if
we compare now the the PDF and uh and
CDF it's even good good habit to say
like if our PDF uh would
be we didn't didn't call it any any
function name but we can give it like
our fun in matlb we could we can call it
like FX we can call the sister function
function of the PDF which will be CDF we
will we can write it with with cap
capital F and well this is just the
notation but the real meaning this is
really telling uh the PDF is only
telling us about the about the density
let's say relative
probability but the CDF will tell us the
the the probability itself yeah so p p r
for
probability
[Music]
probability and we have already already
saw uh one example of the of the CDF
actually at this point you you shouldn't
be shouldn't be surprised that well we
here we calculated what is the
probability that X will take a value
between minus infinity and
infinity here
our distribution
function let's change a variable
slightly such
that I promise it's it's it's helpful so
the value of the distribution function
of a of a particular particular
X so the Z will be a value value of x I
will I will draw it in a in a second it
tells the
probability
that X is less or equal
z
[Music]
um and and the
integral you know
it's let's say uh mathematical
mathematical definition and uh in order
to somehow work work generally it's it's
defined like well we need to start at at
one one end so we pick minus infinity
that that's the end when we when we
start and we we will we can we can
calculate
we can calculate now probability so what
is the probability that X takes value
between minus infinity and Z so what is
the probability that the temperature in
this in this room now is uh below
minus5° yeah we would we would calculate
the integral from our previous
measurements and the and the modeling we
would probably find out that it's that
it's zero because it's usually heating
heating up up here uh
so this is where we take our PDF we plug
in X and we integrate integrate with
respect to
x uh let's try let's try plotting it uh
so if our
if
our
PDF would would look like this and now I
on on purpose already already try to
Center this uh this graph this axis uh
on
the on the mean where if we have the
gaan gaan distribution
well it's the same picture as we have on
the on the
right oh this function would look like
something like something like this the
last one is probably ah
okay it would
it would it would tend uh tend to to
zeros at minus infinity and and plus
infinity and now we will construct our
our CDF
function and uh it
[Music]
uh let's say there will be the mean mean
will be will be
here and let's now pick so our Z is some
number some value of of X so we can pick
Z anywhere
really uh let's
pick let's get some nice
color let's pick that wasn't the color I
meant let's pick Z here let's call it
like this is our our
Z1 so what we are what we are doing
doing now if we are asking what is the
probability that the value of x will be
will will be below Z1 yeah if this is a
temperature I pick 10° in this in this
room so between minus infinity and 10
what's the what's the probability well
we can only
find by by doing the integral we
calculate the area under the curve it's
a same Principle as when we were
counting up the one six 1 16 one six on
the dice to find out whether it's
whether it's even uh we can also uh
again go go back to our dice example
this is very similar to saying what is
the probability that uh that I throw
number uh below uh smaller or equal to
three yeah so 1 2 3 1 six + 1 16 + 1 six
one 1/2 yeah so same same
principle we
consider discr problem not the
continuous one or
Contin shouldn't be like the sum of
the those possibilities I because yes
exactly yeah yeah so uh because I I
don't get it like why should we repr
this problem with
Contin no no no uh the throwing the dice
it's it's it's a it's a discrete problem
it's something which which we can which
we can do uh here uh very very easily
and uh and the well to calculate uh to
get the probability uh to to get that
the probability is one half of throwing
number one two one two or three is a
similar problem
that to if we have now continuous world
this is not not the the number on the on
the dice this is the number on the
thermometer this is the number on my
cell phone for the charge of the charge
of my battery despite you might argue
it's discrete because it only shows you
the the percentage with the with the
whole whole numbers but uh yeah we are
now in the in the continuous continuous
world that's the that's the world which
which we have for for most of our our
measurements good
so if uh well let's let's somehow try to
draw this draw this CDF maybe Point by
point and maybe we could have already
already started what will be
the if this is the probability
then of
course we should expect that the CDF
will will be zero at some point one at
the at the other point yeah we are we
are not uh dealing with the with the
numbers here we actually do not do not
care about how how tall is is is this
point in in reality we T we we
we
uh we care about how much will be the
integral under the curve so if we
integrate the whole curve from minus
infinity to Infinity oh so we should we
should get to the to the point one so we
should at this
point expect some sort of asymptotic
behavior that we will be going towards
towards one yeah because we went through
all possible values temperature
uh what is the uh likelihood what is the
probability that the temperature here is
below 10,000 de yeah it's almost almost
one
yeah uh mathematically practically it's
it's one and the same ASM toote we
should also also we expect on the other
other end because well we are not ruling
out the the the probability that the
temperature here might be minus 10 some
window broke and the or the heating
broke
okay so what happens what happens
between that well
this this Curve will always always be
positive so there is uh no no tricks
with the changing the the signs like we
have a positive surface area and
negative surface area no this is this is
all all nice yeah how do we know it's
it's always positive
we draw it here yeah this one this
particular one is between zero and one
but it's be be it's with without that uh
that constant Square OT 2
pi okay so let's just now say we
calculated the integral and for our
Z1 we get we got the value here what
would it what would it
say the probability
that the temperature in this room is Z1
or less is
0.2
20% yeah here is the on the on the right
hand side we can already say something
about about probability and uh good so
if this is the this is the
derivative if I'm plotting integral then
this this curve is a is a derivative to
that uh to that curve so first we have
the small slopes the slopes increase
increase we get the maximum slope
here which means we get uh we get what
we get inflection
point maybe I need to redraw this yeah
we should get we should get something
like this let let me redraw this uh this
blue blue blue
dot um would it would it work or or or I
just made made it up uh let's take let's
say that we take our Z2 to be to be
equal to Mu so now we are trying to
get
this this
integral including the the previous one
yeah get getting getting the uh area
under half of this half of this
curve apparently we need to get bigger
number than than the than the blue one
than the number we got for Z1 we
increase the temperature so we are
already uh asking uh what
is we are already getting probability
well probably most likely uh somewhere
around 1
that's like counting on one one two one
two three numbers on the on the dice so
this is our
[Music]
Z2 similarly we can find some
point
Z3 and that would be yeah
again again doing doing all this
does it make a bit of bit of
sense
yes no oh well uh yes what what what
does it
mean
the this point is telling us probability
of measuring Z3 or anything below
it very very good question yes yes
please please go ahead
uh it's a it's a standard let's say
mathematical definition of the of the
distri
distribution function
um so it might be not not not that uh
not that intuitive what we actually
would like to would like to get is
uh what we actually would like to get to
is
something let's say let's say of
this this sort so we have uh
we have our probability distribution
again how do we get the to the
probability distribution you uh you will
try it in your in your exercises you
basically just collect some data and you
calculate the you try to calculate the
two parameters of this of this curve
which is mean and the variance or
standard standard deviation
so let's say that we have
our our our PD
PDF this is what we what we measured
from uh from uh this is what we obtained
from from the from the data yeah we
might have measured the standard uh
standard example is like a it's like a
height so if we now take uh take uh us
as a as a population we will also
basically Cate ex value like I mean in
the distribution if we just choose the
different borders of the
integral of the integral yeah then for
example if we want for example exactly
to tell the probability
that here it's going to be 25° let's say
mhm usually we got like
absolute absolute error absolute error
of it so we can choose like
Z1 to be for example
25 plus 25
M
251 for example and Z2 to
be
24.9 yeah this is where where we are
heading exactly yeah yeah uh and we just
need to make sure that the borders are
SED
correctly y y we are we are we are
getting there uh let's let's maybe uh
just try to similar to to throwing the
dicis we can now uh take a take a ruler
and uh and try to try to measure the
height of everybody in this room and uh
I don't know maybe we will see we will
get like three people are 185 CM uh two
people are 180 cm and another uh another
uh and another person is
170 and one person is 190 and well
similarly to how we started to throwing
the dice we were not getting the uniform
distribution it was just our experience
what we what we expected what we what we
knew about so uh we can we can then then
try try fit and you will try this in
your exercises try to fit the the normal
normal distribution because once we have
it then we are then we are back to so we
get data from the data we get mean we
get the uh we get the standard deviation
because then we can start asking the the
question that that Adam already already
already
meant no
line so let's say this is this is our
our
mean if it would be standard
distribution the mean would be zero we
can always discard some number to to
make to make our distribution standard
and now let's move and let's
discard or at this is what you meant
yeah discard or at some some specific
numbers and we can discard like one two
three and and so and so on in in general
we can just try try discarding this uh
this this Sigma here
um in principle oh sorry no no
no if we if we look back uh look back
here
our our X and our Sigma are somehow uh
should somehow live in the in in the in
the same world right because let's say
if x is temperature then in the
numerator we get uh Kelvin squared and
uh in the denominator such that did
works out we should get uh we should get
again Kelvin squared and this Kelvin is
only coming from the unit of the
standard standard
deviation so we can then say we can then
take this standard deviation it's a
constant yeah so for for our standard de
uh standard distribution this will be
minus one this will be one yeah in case
the standard deviation is equal to one
but we can can go even to more popular
intervals like minus 2 standard
deviations
and
plus two standard
deviations what we can what we
can now now try to ask is exactly this
thing the height height in our
population in this in this classroom the
mean of it uh let's say it's uh
1761 through 1
92 whatever whatever number um so who
has who has this height nobody yeah
because we got this number through some
averaging through some mean but we can
start asking well what is who has the
height between
170 and maybe 18
which that's quite a
big well different it's just just just
okay okay so let's let's do it smaller
so one
174 and
yeah yeah maybe we again do do not do
not find anybody but at least we can we
can calculate the the the the
probability the probability of this is
is zero yeah because the the integral is
from uh the integral is on is on one
point it's the area under under this
this point is actually zero but this
this already starts starts making making
sense to ask these questions
so the
standard or more uh more usual way is to
is to think about these uh these Sigma
intervals some years ago it used to be
very popular that we were looking at the
results from the CERN uh whether they
whether the neutrinos will surpass the
speed of light whether the H bosone
would be discovered they call uh
Discovery if they measure something with
plus Min with the plus minus six
standard deviations and let's see how
how big this this probability is
so let's ask now the question what is
the probability
that our
X is
between I should write it our X is
between its standard deviation minus 1
Sigma
and standard
deviation what is it me
standard mean + one standard standard
deviation
um we can again I mean this is very very
similar
to to what we already saw for the for
the distribution
function and we can actually say okay
let's
just let's just take
the the lower bound of this interval to
be the start of our of our integral and
take the take the upper bound to be
uh to be the upper limit of the integral
let's take our our
PDF and let's do the let's do the
integration let's say that we are in
this world of standard standard
distribution which means uh that our our
mean is zero and our standard deviation
standard deviation is
one and let's try whether our MLB will
come to the rescue
again why does it need to connect so so
many
times do you use it on on tablet the M
lab don't do
that
connect m is like its own cloud and
usually all scripts right there
yeah
but yeah but I mean I you know I didn't
wait didn't go on a one week vacation
before since the last time I I use it it
was 20 minutes ago
okay well whatever good so let's uh
let's now do the integral now I have our
our function for function written
written here so
that we have it directly 1 / < tk2 * pi
e to the N of on and this is already the
function where mu is equal to 0 and
sigma is equal to is equal to
1 and what should we
get we get 0.
6827 so the probability what we just
calculated is actually not the case only
for like uh one uh one specific example
it's actually actually General once we
would know the mean and the most
importantly the standard deviation we
can we can then say for any standard
deviation for any mean uh the
probability that our values temperature
in the room height of the people in in
the in the room will be between plusus
one standard deviation it's is 60
how much was it
6872 27 27
whoops and we don't need to don't need
to stop there sounds like relatively
small small probability if we want to
have to be like more more certain what
what probability would we would we like
to have one is impossible so what is the
or 100 person is impossible what what do
we
want how much probability would you
would you uh would you bet your uh life
on your right hand on
yeah what's the probability that the
plane crashes when you are when you are
loading it
um let's try at least uh to to go with
these
values of
Sigma just to increase them increase
them in in in
multiples so two Sigma or plus minus two
standard standard deviation yes standard
deviations away
well again
reconnecting uh do I have it still yeah
let's just take the boundaries change
the boundaries of this of this
integral not bad yeah already
95 point
something
95.45% of the of the cases so if we just
ask and well maybe I draw this picture
intentionally intentionally that way it
already starts
to starts to to to suggest this that so
the probability uh in this one Sigma
band so plus uh minus one Sigma plus +
one Sigma 68% if we just extend so 2
Sigma 2 Sigma then already 95% that's
not bad yeah if if you are designing uh
controller
for uh for the temperature in in your in
your room maybe you don't don't care
about the 5% of the of the cases when
when it will will go go wrong yeah so if
you want to
be
even even more
certain we can go to
to three how much do you
expect 98
98 let's see ah I should put three
here not bad gesses let's see ah
99 98 yeah some somewhere in between so
99 what will be the good color let's say
say this one 99 73 something like
[Music]
that that's almost everything yeah and
and you you will see if uh if our if our
certainty
about certainty if we if we say this is
the mean mean height of the of the
population and the standard deviation is
is one one cm that means that almost
everybody in this room would be uh 1 cm
would
be that okay this this will be like this
two Sigma interval yeah like two two cm
below six 2 cm above six so
95% people almost everybody will be will
be between one 74 and one 178 so
probably the standard deviation would be
would be some something something
slightly slightly higher
uh let's now
see how we can how we can calculate this
from the from the
data let just let's just do it do it
quickly uh so that
if we if we collected some some data
points X1 X2 X
xn so
the me with this with this head would
actually actually mean our U sampled uh
sampled sampled mean because we are not
getting the the exact uh
uh exact uh exact mean value but we base
it on only on on some of our
observations this is the same thing why
through jet GPT you don't get the
correct answer but you get the answer
that was found on the
internet some of the answers checked by
some checked by some people and some of
the answers even checked and answered by
by the experts so GPT is a is some mean
sample
uh uh mean sampled from from some from
some
population and this
is very easy thing which you might you
might expect yeah we do the we do the
average uh arithmetic average we uh sum
together all the values and we divide by
the number of the of the of the trials
same as we did with our one six
probability of the of the
dice how to find the standard deviation
or let's say variance that's uh that's
uh
more more intuitive is again going to be
an average but it's now the average
of
how our data points not finished so far
so far so good so far so far same so how
our samples are different from what we
calculated in the in the line above so
from our our
mean and since this different can can be
positive or or
negative uh this Square come comes to
the comes to the rescue so standard
deviation is average distance of like
our Heights in this in this room the
temperatures or in this room throughout
the throughout the year from its mean
value unfortunately this is the thing
that GPT uh cannot cannot calculate
because uh for J GPT like getting one of
these samples is one training of 40
billion parameters which consumes couple
of million dollars
so we would need to get at least couple
of trainings and that's nobody going to
going to pay
for okay any questions to
that good intro to the statistics was it
too far from what you remembered
recalled no okay okay oh if it wasn't
too far then you you you should you
should have uh chased me to to be to be
faster
good if no more questions then thank you
very much and see you next week